summer could be a good time to encourage
teenagers to put down their phones and
to enjoy some outdoor time fifty percent
of teens report that they feel addicted
to their cell phones a new study in the
Journal of child development shows
nighttime usage of cell phones can
increase anxiety and depression and
teenagers and even reduce self-esteem
this is the first study that shows a
direct link between screen time and
mental health researchers note that
rates of anxiety and depression and
young people have actually risen over
seventy percent over the past couple of
decades psychologists and CBS News
contributor Lisa d'amour is here welcome
Lisa Micro parenting guru always but
this is fascinating as it's the first
time it's looked at nighttime cell use
and depression what's important about
this study is that it shows us a pathway
we've suspected that there's a problem
here we've seen correlational studies
but this shows us that teens using their
phones late at night leads to disrupted
sleep which leads to increased
depression emotional fragility and
sometimes acting out does it matter what
they're doing with their phones if it's
social media if they're just texting
does that make a difference well we know
that there are some things teenagers can
do that are upsetting to them but what's
important about this study is even if
they're having a great time even if
they're being super appropriate on their
phone if the phone is getting in the way
of the sleep they need it still causes
harm so this is a constant battle for
many parents right as you know so the
question is what what the advice from
the extra that is on what to do sure so
this is really hard I will not say there
are simple solution I said so the first
thing you can do is to try to get out in
front of it when your kids are little
so put a power strip in your bedroom
have all the technology charged in the
parents room overnight make that the
default family habit you will lose
ground on this when you have a teenager
but if that's the default it's easier to
keep that ground I think then the other
thing is we have to model good habits we
have to be good about our own phones and
our own technology and our own sleep and
then we can say to teenagers look if I'm
protecting my sleep and not protecting
yours it would be like I got in the car
and put on my seat belt but didn't ask
you to put on your seat belt when I read
that I was saying to you before isn't it
this should be a problem for all of us
this isn't just a teenage problem this
is not just a teenage problem I mean in
many ways adults are is deep in as their
teens these days
but again that's the place where we can
say look I empathize I know how hard it
is to put down the phone so we're not
creating these rules for you or creating
these rules for everybody and this study
looks particularly at teenage girls it's
very troubling for them as well why is
that so one of the things we know from
the research and this goes way back is
that teenage girls get less sleep than
teenage boys and this is long before
technology and we think it's because
they hit puberty earlier so what this
new study makes us much more concerned
about is sleep is already fragile for
teenage girls so we want to make sure
that technology doesn't interfere with
any teenagers sleep but we want to keep
a special eye on the girls because we
are seeing very high rates of depression
look at those average hours spend time
Media nine hours and that's not just for
the teens that's the whole point because
we think we're setting a good example
and then we turn around and we're just
yeah looking at our screens - right so
it's one of those things where everybody
needs electronic curfews and I think we
can sort of just say these are universal
rules you said before it does matter
social media or texting or what they're
doing on the phone but should we be
limiting how much time teenagers are
spending on social media yeah I mean I
think the way to think about it is we
don't want technology to get in the way
of the things that promote health for
teenagers
so that's sleep which they actually need
nine hours a night which in the summer
is probably their best chance of getting
that they need in time person with real
human beings they need to be working and
learning and growing they need to be
physically active if they aren't doing
those things because they're on social
media then they're on social media too
much lately maybe we can all stay off so
dollars in an alarm clock bring back a
dream machine nine hours of sleep zones
I know I'm possible and amazing Lisa do
more thank you very much that's